hey vsauce michael here do you want to
be infected with ebola without having to
leave your own home or
deal with other people well you might be
in luck
you can already download an ebola virus
genome
right here on the internet right now and
if you're willing to wait
a few years for 3d bio printing
technology to progress
a little bit you can just acquire one
then
submit the genome to it and ta-da all
you can print
ebola or anthrax
or whatever it is you wish to mass
produce at home
to wipe out humanity
are humans going to go extinct soon
will human extinction be anthropogenic
that is the result of human action
or will it be one of the good
old-fashioned kinds of extinction
earth's history knows pretty well
the global catastrophic risks survey
issued by oxford university's
future of humanity institute placed our
risk of extinction
before the year 2100 at 19
now you might be thinking whatever blah
blah blah armageddon
it'll be okay humans are too smart to go
extinct
maybe you're right but it's difficult to
predict the distant future with a lot of
certainty
what's really cool though is that if you
embrace that uncertainty
a simple argument can show that human
extinction
soon is actually more probable
it's called the doomsday argument
imagine a giant urn that contains either
10 balls numbered 1 to 10 or
a million balls numbered one to a
million
now you don't know which is the case but
you are
allowed to pull out one ball
you go ahead and do that and it is ball
number
four that's pretty strong evidence in
favor of the 10 ball
condition because drawing a 4 from a set
of 1 through 10
is a 1 in 10 chance but drawing 4 from a
million different numbers
is a 1 in a million chance
by analogy you are also a numbered
ball you are a human who knows
approximately what your birth number is
it's probably somewhere around 100
billion
that's how many other humans were most
likely born
before you were importantly you didn't
get to decide which birth number
you would have so just like the number
four ball
you are a random sample from the set of
all humans who will ever live
the doomsday argument points out that
from
200 billion people there's a 50 chance
that a randomly chosen person
like you would be born in the first 100
billion
whereas if there will be 10 trillion
humans
there's only a 1 chance that any given
human
say you would happen to be born within
the first
100 billion either you
are special and lucky to be born so
improbably
early in the story of humanity
or your birth number is to be expected
because there will not be tens of
trillions of humans
human extinction will be sooner
rather than later but before you become
too convinced that the end is nigh
keep in mind that the doomsday argument
is not
uncontroversial one problem it might
have
is a reference class problem are you
really
a random sample from the set of all
humans who will ever
be born well if you believe that in the
not so distant future
humans will be quite different than they
are today
for instance they'll be full of more 3d
printed organs
the mere fact that right now there
aren't very many humans with that trait
could be evidence that you aren't a
random sample from the set of all humans
just from the set of all humans like
you like those around you those born
earlier in human history also
the doomsday argument doesn't consider
the likelihoods of
actual threats or human advantages over
those threats
in the future it just assumes that we
don't know which way the balance will
lie that human extinction soon and
human extinction later are equally
likely but maybe you don't believe that
maybe you are convinced that human
ingenuity will always
stay one step ahead of any extinction
event thrown at it
you could be right but there's reason to
doubt
that optimism for example
the fermi paradox if it is likely that
intelligent life forms in our universe
are capable of living for billions
and billions of years
where are they why are the skies so
silent
perhaps it is because extinction level
threat events
are just too common for intelligent life
anywhere to ever catch up
so does this mean we should just
give up the voluntary human extinction
movement
thinks so founded in 1991
its supporters believe that humans are
a negative influence on earth and
always will be thus we have a moral
obligation to just
stop reproducing right now and fade away
but what would a computer do in a way
that's kind of what tom 7 did he created
a
program that plays video games the
program
came up with novel techniques and
strategies for playing games and even
exploited glitches
humans didn't know about or at least
hadn't told it about
he also had the program play other games
like
tetris which i think is relevant to our
question
the computer struggled to figure out
what to do
you see the computer wasn't programmed
to consider future repercussions far
enough ahead
to notice that stacking tetraminos in
certain ways
made a big difference on one run
when faced with imminent demise the
computer did
something eerie
rather than lose and receive a game over
it just paused the game
forever tom 7 describes the computer's
reasoning
like this the only winning move
is to not play and that's right
if you pause a game forever
you will never lose that game
but you'll also never win that game or
achieve
a high score now we might not know
what achieving a sentient life high
score in this universe
means or whether or not we're capable of
achieving one
we might also sometimes panic when the
future looks bleak
but if we keep playing and keep learning
chances are we could eventually figure
it out
and start playing really well
so thanks for continuing to play
for being here and as always thanks for
watching